are we up for this are we exhausted and
defeated are we ready to go okay Ron
Larsen and I on the one hand and and
Andrew Roberts on the other been having
an argument Andrew does not like to be
introduced as a brilliant speaker and so
let me say that he's a miserable speaker
I wouldn't expect much tonight so it's
hard to write a biography of Churchill
for all the reasons you know there's so
much all the greatest things that ever
happened in scale are all in his life
and he was in the middle of them and so
there's been one really great biography
of Winston Churchill written and I told
you last night it's 9,000 pages long and
I used to say to an incredulous Martin
Gilbert you know not many people are
going to read this and he would say why
not and I would say yeah right so who is
written a good biography of Churchill in
manageable scale one person a biography
that can be relied on a biography that
captures the parts of it and the parts
of it are solemnity and fun ceremony and
adventure aggressiveness and restraint
consistency and change it's a drama it's
a huge drama and of course if it spread
over 9,000 pages you can see it one way
and if it's spread over a tiny little
book of only 1,000 pages
then you can see it in a different way
and I have waited my life to say when
people walk up to me and say what should
I read of Churchill I say the same thing
Richard langworth says I say read my
early life and then if you get hooked
I'll tell you the next thing if they say
what should I read about Churchill I
struggle with that Martin Gilbert wrote
a one-volume it's very good
it's a rival for the best Andrews is
like it bit shorter and more fun and
that's such an achievement and I will
tell you I've known a long time and I
know that he's prepared his whole life
to write this book although I'm not sure
he always knew that's what he was doing
he wrote about Halifax Churchill's sort
of friend and enemy alike he wrote about
imminent Churchill ian's and that's all
the people of Churchill's time and what
they said about each other and it's a
it's patterned after a classic book from
the 1920s I think called
eminent Victorians and if you want to
understand who knew who and what they
were like and even who was sleeping with
whom they weren't always of the same
surname then he did bad and you have to
dig to do that and and also not make it
just phony he's written many fine books
we're trying to remember when we met and
it was we best I can tell sometime in
the early 1990s when Doug Jeffrey got
him to give a speech for where we used
to work at the Claremont Institute and
when he finished his speech I said to
myself and depending I said one of these
days that man is gonna write a great
book about rinsing Churchill now he's
done it
Andrew Roberts
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen it's a great honor
to be invited to address you this
evening and thank you very much indeed
Larry for those tremendously kind words
I will always remember being introduced
as a miserable speaker last night at
dinner Randolph Churchill said that the
conclusion of the official biography
after so many years and 15 point 1
million words was an achievement a
monument not unlike the building of
Blenheim Palace and a few people laughed
and I don't think they should do because
actually when you look at it there are
many civilizations that have lost their
buildings lost their architectures lost
their their palaces but their literature
has survived and that I think is going
to be the case with Winston Churchill so
I think it was a perfectly reasonable
analogy to make in fact that what has
been concluded here this year by
Hillsdale and by Larry and by Richard
langworth without whom by the way I
could not have written my biography of
Churchill and Soren Geiger and the rest
of the team really is a monument that
will last for the ages
[Music]
there are descriptions of there's the
great Napoleon created the description
of Egypt back in the 20s re back in the
19th century and that was 21 volumes
Cambridge University brought out the
science in China volumes 22 volumes in
the 1950s Toronto University the letters
of Disraeli which where they ran out of
money and that never was never finished
and I think therefore that what has been
created here this this official
biography with all of its companion
volumes will be seen as the greatest
publishing achievements of the 21st
century the torch was handed on by the
dying Martin Gilbert to Larry and he has
now finally finished this fulfilled this
this sacred task it must fill him with a
sense of powerful catharsis which I
think we noticed that a sense of very
much in in Larry's speech yesterday and
when you look scientists it's often said
standing on the shoulders of giants and
Stein standing on the shoulders of
Newton and so on and if we Churchill
writer every church an author and
biographer is effectively standing on
the church on the shoulders of Martin
Gilbert's this great figure who
dedicated his life to these volumes and
now it can be said I think that every
future Churchill historian is standing
on the shoulders of Martin but also
Larry and Richard and Soren and this and
this incredible team and really we
cannot do enough to thank you
it will be it is indeed now a documents
as well as of course of history it's
also a documents for liberty and for
those who love Liberty and will be used
by future generations by people who love
Liberty there's a sign at the front here
that says pursuing truth defending
Liberty since 1844 and as long as of
course we can ignore the bit about 1844
which for an Englishman is yesterday
basically the the rest of it though is
entirely true because it is a question
of pursuing truth and also of defending
Liberty so there is a real sense I think
that hills dales defining mission
statements is intimately bound up with
the creation of this this extraordinary
15 point 1 million word document and for
that I think that future generations
will salute you
my book walking with destiny
which by the way with regard to the
title it's not true what a waggish
friend of mine said to me the other day
that I did it in order to try to sell as
many copies transatlantic Lee owing to
the fact the Americans love destiny and
British people love walking is an
attempt to to unpick to to look into
this fabulous statement that Churchill
made in the last paragraph of the first
volume of his war memoirs The Gathering
Storm in which he famously said that all
my la my past life has been but a
preparation for this hour and this trial
but also a attempt to look at the
beginning part of that sentence where he
said I felt as if I were walking with
destiny because Churchill's it strikes
me as essentially in trying to
understand Winston Churchill to
appreciate that he had a sense of
personal and private destiny which was
something that drove him on he of course
was only 16 years old when as a as a
schoolboy at Harrow school
Churchill was almost entirely self
educated because he had to be because he
went to Harrow not a joke I'd have made
in front of Randolph Churchill yesterday
but nonetheless is clearly true he said
that that in his life he said this to
there to his great friend Merlin Devens
he said in our lives we shall see
terrible upheavals great struggles and
that I shall be called upon to save
London and to save England and all of
the things that happen to him as a as a
young man indeed had already happened to
him up until that point served to
underline this sense of private destiny
especially the extraordinary number the
remarkable number of close brushes with
death that he had he was of course born
to
prematurely that in itself in Victorian
England was a close brush with death he
was stabbed in the stomach by a school
friend at the age of 10 clearly not a
very close friend he at the age of 11
nearly died of pneumonia and on that
occasion the doctors administered brandy
to the eleven-year-old both orally and
rectally you might have thought that
they would have put you off brandy for
life but didn't in Winston Churchill's
case he very maybe died in a in a house
fire he very nearly died in a terrible
near accident in Lake Geneva he had two
plane crashes she was involved in three
car crashes on the front of my book with
a wonderful picture of yosef cash in
1941 you can see this huge scarred and
the center of his forehead which used to
go red in meetings of the Chiefs of
Staff of the Second World War and and
that came of course as a result of
nearly being killed in on Fifth Avenue
and an 76th Street crossing the road he
was an Englishman so he looked in the
wrong direction as he as he crossed the
road and so it's a and so those by the
way ladies and gentlemen only the
peacetime close brushes with death in
wartime he took part in five campaigns
on four continents took part of course
in the last great cavalry charge of the
British Empire at the Battle of Omdurman
where where 25 percent of his units the
21st Lancers were killed or wounded the
following year he his armored train was
ambushed by the burrs in the South
African War where 34% of his unit were
killed or wounded and then two months
later after that he escaped from a
prisoner of war camp in
south africa and cross 300 miles of
enemy territory at one point he had to
hide down a mineshaft and when the
candle guttered out he could feel rats
scurrying over his face this is a man
therefore Owen the First World War of
course only five minutes after leaving
his dugout in the front line he insisted
on going into the front line he could
have stayed back at battalion
headquarters he was left tenant colonel
of the 6th battalion of the Royal Scots
Fusiliers he could have stayed back if
he'd wanted to at battalion headquarters
but he never believed in in asking his
men to do anything that he wouldn't do
himself and five minutes after leaving a
dugout in the front line it's scored a
direct hit from a German whiz-bang
high-explosive shell decapitating
everyone inside and on that occasion he
said that he felt he could feel the
invisible wings beating above him he was
there for somebody who did believe in
the Almighty although actually
theologically if you look into it
carefully the sole duty of the Almighty
seems to have been to take care of
Winston Churchill and what this
extraordinary sense of private destiny
did for him was tool it was to give him
a calmness a extraordinary sense of calm
that was to allow him to make jokes even
during the the great crises of the
Second World War when in confidence
motions in the House of Commons
they're very rare by the way they seem
to be cropping up a little bit more
often now but under normal circumstances
we don't have them very often and
Winston Churchill had two of them in
1942 and in one of them he said that
when the defects and the teething
troubles of the a.22 tank became
apparent to all it was appropriately
rechristened
the Churchill and the key line in that
the key word really in that gag is
appropriately because Churchill realize
that he himself had made many blunders
and many mistakes in his life he had got
the Dardanelles wrong he had got the
the gold-standard wrong and the
abdication crisis the blackened hands
and women suffrage and so on but the
great thing about Churchill was that he
learned from his mistakes and the way in
which he learned from the Dardanelles
which by the way was a brilliant concept
brilliant idea to have tried to have got
the Royal Navy from the eastern
Mediterranean through the Straits of the
Dardanelles and to have anchored it off
Constantinople modern-day Istanbul had
it come off it would have been one of
the great strategic coos in the history
of warfare because it would have taken
the Ottoman Empire out of the Great War
but it went wrong because of the
implementation of it which had nothing
to do with him he was back in London but
if but what he learned from the
appalling defeat in the Dardanelles
because of course after the the break
for the attempted breakthrough on the
18th of March 1915 five weeks later they
then undertook a massive amphibious
assault on the gut on the Gallipoli
Peninsula on the west side of the
Straits and ultimately we lost a hundred
and forty seven thousand killed or
wounded and people still shouted what
about the Dardanelles at Churchill even
into the 1930s in public meetings but
what Churchill learned from the
Dardanelles was that he was never to
overrule the Chiefs of Staff at all in
the Second World War and he was a
politician who constantly learned from
his mistakes I'm often asked why I
should have written a book on Churchill
considering that at moment there are
1009 biographies of Winston Churchill
that's what what Ronald Cohen has as
added up and and so why on earth should
one try to present a one thousand and
tenth to thee to the public and the
answer is that since the last major
biography of Churchill there have been a
extraordinary avalanche of new
information about him the Majesty the
Queen allowed me to be the first
Churchill biographer to use her father's
Diaries
and the King met Churchill every Tuesday
of the Second World War to Buckingham
Palace and Churchill trusted the King
with all of the great secrets of the
Second World War he told him about the
nuclear secret he told him about the
ultra decrypts from the enigma machines
he told him which generals and admirals
were going to be hard and fired under
what circumstances he told in which
countries were going to be invaded when
so on and the King wrote everything down
and there's no real reason why they
should necessarily have got on with one
another because of course the King had
been a supporter of Neville Chamberlain
and the policy of appeasement and
Churchill had been a supporter of his
elder brother King Edward the eighth
during the abdication crisis but they
did and they did immediately and
certainly by the time of the Blitz and
the Battle of Britain and so that's a
wonderful new source in fact Churchill
was the first judge was the only one of
the Kings for prime ministers who to who
the king referred to called by his
Christian name and he calls him his
friend in these in these Diaries so
that's a wonderful new source another is
the diaries of Ivan my ski the Soviet
ambassador 1932 to 43 and and they're -
they've just come out in Moscow over the
last four or five years and those have
been invaluable as were the 41 sets of
papers that have been deposited at
Churchill College archives in Cambridge
since the last major biography of
Churchill 41 including Mary Soames the
Churchill's daughters Diaries from 1940
I was very fortunate also to be able to
discover the verbatim accounts of the
War Cabinet and those which which I've
used and which have now been used in a
in a Churchill biography for the first
time and the Churchill family were
tremendously generous in allowing me to
have exclusive access to Tamela Harlan's
love letters Pamela Harriman of course
who was Winston Churchill's
daughter-in-law and who led a very
active romantic life during the Second
World War I think it's fair to say as
well as of course being married to
Randolph Churchill and having a baby by
him during the Second World War
she also famously had an affair with
Averell Harriman the FDR's envoi and
jock Whitney and ed Murrow and the great
great American journalist and general
Kenneth Anderson and marshal of the Air
Force of Charles Portal and someone we
just know others Jerry anyhow the the
Churchill was very fortunate that I had
exclusive access to her papers although
clearly nobody had exclusive access to
her and sorry about that ladies
gentleman what it tells you what these
extraordinary new is avalanche of new
informations cornucopia that has come
out over the last six eight years or so
still told you it on top of everything
that we would know already from this
from this magnificent official biography
and it's and its companion volumes is
that Churchill was not the buttoned up
Victorian era Stoke rat of his age and
class and background he was in fact an
extraordinarily emotional man a man
driven by his passions on some 50
occasions during the Second World War
Winston Churchill burst into tears in
public it would be very off-putting to
see a prime minister burst into tears in
public apart from it happening the week
before last but but it's unusual
otherwise to for it to to happen and we
and and so but people were not surprised
when Churchill did it own to the fact
that they appreciated that he was a
highly eccentric and finally unusual man
who's driven as I say by his passions he
was a throwback effectively to an
earlier era he was a romantic Regency
figure
an aristocrat of the Regency period a
time when people wore their hearts on
their sleeves I think it's worth
wondering why oh and by the way when we
talk about his eccentricities of course
he was broke almost all his life he only
really got into in out of debt when he
signed his contract for the the war
memoirs his great Walmart when my woman
was after the Second World War but up
until that point he there were two
occasions when he very nearly had to
sell Chartwell his beloved beautiful
manor house in Kent that I know you've
all been to and so what he did was of
course to write his 37 books and his
over 800 articles and essays and so on
and these were these allow us to have an
insight into his mind that is not given
to very many biographers and rather of
other people and and Churchill in the
1930s would write by would write on
articles about pretty much anything and
so you get the situation that if an
editor turned down an article by him he
would do what a lot of us journalists
too which is just keep the article and
wait for a different editor and so by
the time of the Second World War when of
course any editor would publish anything
that the British prime minister was had
written he brought out a few a few ideas
and you so you get the situation on the
7th of March 1942 a terrible time of
course ladies and gentlemen in the in
the history of the Second World War the
Russian army was on the retreat through
the Ukraine British army was on the
retreat through the North African
littoral the Japanese had taken
one-eighth of the of the planet and this
was the point at which the British Prime
Minister published an article in The
Illustrated Sunday Herald entitled are
there men on the moon
it's concluded that there probably were
men on the moon and there were certainly
such things as aliens and UFOs again
were to resume to publish an article are
there men on the moon in in the Sunday
Times next weekend
I think people be a little concerned but
they weren't with Churchill because they
realize that this Matt had this
extraordinary sense of their of X
interesting I want to try to kill to two
myths that have been around for ages
about him there are so many myths if
anybody by the way wants to go through
all of the myths about Churchill and to
see the way in which they are crushed
you should read Richard langworth book
on on the myths of Winston Churchill it
is utterly superb and an invaluable but
there are two in particular I think that
have been around for so long now that
they really do need to be nailed the
first is that he was a some kind of
manic-depressive the only time in his
entire career that he used the phrase
Black Dog was in July 1911 when he was
writing to his wife Clementine and at
that time it was a well-known phrase
used by Edwardian governesses and
nannies to explain ill-tempered children
he chaired over a thousands meetings of
the war committee of the defense
committee of the war cabinet and and I
simply don't believe that he was
somebody who suffered from manic
depression or as I've seen in some books
bipolar disease it's a it's a both of
those diseases are debilitating
illnesses and he was able to to chair
these meetings until three o'clock in
the morning the other was that he was an
alcoholic I don't believe this either
he was somebody clearly who was able to
to deal with a tremendous amount of
alcohol he had an iron Constitution for
alcohol but it was as he said always his
his servant and never his master there's
only one occasion on the in the poll of
the 2194 days of the second world
or that Churchill was drunk and on that
occasion it went on til 3 o'clock in the
morning he'd been drinking whiskey and
and what they did on that occasion was
to hold the same meeting the next
morning as though the earlier one hadn't
happened it was CP Scott who said of
Churchill that Winston Churchill
couldn't have been an alcoholic because
no alcoholic could have drunk that much
and of course there's a very famous
story about when after his retirement
when he used to invite his invite people
pretty much anyone to to come to
Chartwell to see his wonderful
collection of books there in his library
and to see his study and then they wound
up in the drawing room and at six
o'clock he'd invite them for a drink
and he did this to two American Mormons
one of whom said to him that strong
drink rage a--the and stingeth like a
serpent and church were applied I've
long been looking for a drink like that
[Laughter]
so how was it ladies lemon how was it
that this extraordinary man this
eccentric figure this romantic figure
this this passionate figure was able to
be not just the most important British
politician to spot Hitler and the Nazis
for what they really were but in many
ways the only British major British
politician in the 1930s to be able to do
that and the answer was and by the way
not of course it wasn't his only act of
prescience he also before the First
World War spotted the danger posed by
Prussian militarism and after the Second
World War that posed by Soviet Communism
especially in Eastern Europe how was it
that he had this extraordinary foresight
for sites so important it strikes me
because these are the three greatest
threats of the 20th century he spotted
them others didn't they were far more
important than all the trivial business
to do with with the gold standard all
the abdication crisis the key moments he
got right and others didn't and it
strike me strikes me ladies and
gentlemen that these things come his his
prescience comes from three things the
first was that he was a phyllo see might
he liked Jews he'd grown up with Jews he
appreciated them he admired their
contribution to Western civilization
he'd been a Zionist at the time of the
Balfour Declaration and earlier he was
somebody therefore who was able to place
Hitler and the Nazis to see the threat
that they posed to have an early warning
system about that and and I think that's
a vital in order to understand the way
in which he spotted what was about to
happen the second thing was that he was
an historian and one of the things that
makes me proud to be an historian is
that Winston Churchill was one and he
was able to place the danger in its long
continuum of history certainly of
British history of the threats
hegemonist ik threats to the European
balance of power so he was able to see
it in terms
of philip ii of spain and the spanish
armada and louis xiv and the the great
dangers have shown in the war of Spanish
Succession which of course is own great
ancestor the first Duke of Marlborough
John Churchill had been instrumental in
defeating and then Napoleon and then the
Kaiser against who himself had fought
and so he was able to see this threat in
the panoply of dangerous historical
dangers and the first thing was that he
was somebody who had come up against
fanaticism in his life on the northwest
frontier of course and in the Sudan in
that case both cases Islamic
fundamentalists fanaticism but he saw
the same tropes in the political
fanaticism of the Nazis in a way that
the other prime ministers of the 1930s
men like Stanley Martin Stanley Baldwin
and Ramsay MacDonald and Neville
Chamberlain were not able to do and so
you have therefore somebody who has the
who has the foresight he also has the
extraordinary moral courage that goes
with his physical carriages it's as
great as his physical courage he was
somebody who didn't employ speech
writers ever who didn't employ spin
doctors who didn't take notice of
opinion polls this marvelous moment in
the Second World War when he was told
that that politicians should keep their
ears to the ground and he said that he
didn't believe that people would respect
politicians who were caught in so
ungainly a posture and and so he you
knew what you got from Winston Churchill
was something that came straight from
him but none of this ladies and
gentlemen would have mattered none of
this would have worked unless he had
also had eloquence extraordinary
rhetorical ability the capacity to make
people listen to him to to persuade them
to urge them to listen to him because of
the quality of his rhetoric and his and
his aura
he was once asked by by Koval his
private secretary
what were the tricks of the trade what
were the techniques that he used in
order to infuse the nation and in the
civilized world in 1942 41 and those
great great wartime speeches
morale-boosting speeches and he said
really it came down to three things the
first was to keep your sentences short
each sentence should have one thought
and one thought only that it's
attempting to get over don't bother with
all the sub clauses and so on the second
was to keep your words short and don't
don't show off by using long words use
the short words the ones that that
actually a right for the sentence and
the third was if at all possible to use
words that the english-speaking peoples
use in their own common parlance and
have done for a thousand years words
that can be found in anglo-saxon and Old
English and so when you look at the
great pair Asian the last paragraph of
the we shall fight on the beaches speech
of 4th of June 1940 where he is telling
the British people what they are going
to do when when the Germans landed in
southern England and he look at anyway
he said of course we should fight on the
beaches and on the landing grounds in
the streets and in the hills fight with
ever-growing confidence in the air
ending of course with that line we shall
never surrender when you look at the a
hundred and forty one words of that
peroration that last paragraph all but
two of them come from Old English the
only two exceptions being confidence
which comes from the Latin and surrender
which comes from the French
so to say to conclude ladies and
gentlemen you have asked an Englishman
here to sweet
to conclude ladies and gentlemen man who
makes mistakes
terrible blunders on occasion but learns
from them somebody who has a moral
courage equal to his physical courage
somebody who has tremendous foresight
extraordinary foresight driven very
largely by his sense of history and
somebody who has the eloquence to ask
people to listen to him even though they
don't agree with him and they don't want
to hear what he has to say the warnings
that he has to give the detailed
warnings before the Second World War
about the importance of high defence
spending especially in the air and you
put all of these things together and you
have somebody who is capable of going
even beyond what he had predicted for
himself
as a 16 year old school boy because he
wasn't just able to save London and to
save England but actually he saved
civilization itself thank you very much
indeed
thank you so much let's thank you that's
very kind of you take it thank you thank
you very much indeed that's so kind of
you now ladies and gentlemen we've got
Superman time for questions and answers
[Music]
it's a great opportunity who would like
to ask a question
fighting the Boers
Oh got a very good question Melissa and
I think I think that it's very important
to remember his in it when we think
about his very early drive to remember
his parentage and his background his
father of course Lord Randolph Churchill
was Chancellor of the Exchequer in a
Conservative government and have been
the man who had annexed Burma to the
crown in 1886 and his mother Jennie
Jerome an American had had an important
influence on him as well she didn't
actually take much notice of him early
on in his life well done thank you
and he actually for the first first six
months of 1884 when she was when he was
nine years old she only saw him for six
and a half hours in in those six months
and what he did instead of that was to
was to be interested in history
especially British history was to be
interested in military history and and
he he really reckoned that the way that
he was going to be able to continue his
father's political legacy was to get
into the House of Commons early they had
no money and so the way he was going to
do that was to join the army and and
show tremendous courage on the field of
battle which is what he did on five
occasions in in on four continents and
so he was somebody who had this
tremendous sense of Destiny and I think
to answer you he always believed that he
was going to impose himself on history
he was not somebody who fell for a
moment for the wig or determinist or
Marxist sense of his
stree where the individual doesn't
matter and everything about history is
just driven by dark and personal forces
as TS Eliot called them he had a great
man view of history in which individuals
really can stamp their personalities on
the age and he intended from a very
young girl either very young an early
age to be one of those personalities
gentle now no no he disagree with me all
the time not to overrule them he had
great clashes with them yes yes that's a
good question
no he he was constantly disagreeing with
them and but what he didn't do was when
all three of them agreed on on something
he did not use his constitutional powers
as Minister of Defense and of course as
Prime Minister to overrule them he would
argue with them he would debate with
them he would he would bring in his his
own Statistical Office he would use
decrypts from the from the ultra boffins
at Bletchley Park he would he would
shout sometimes he would bang the table
he would on occasionally burst into
tears he would do anything to try and
get them to change their minds but if he
failed and very often he did fail
because he was up against the
six-foot-four flinty Ulsterman General
Sir Alan Brooke later
Field Marshal Lord Alan Breck who was a
he was a extremely tough minded man who
would sit across the the cabinet table
from Churchill breaking pencils in half
saying no I disagree with you prime
minister but but and so the thing that
he learnt was was that even if he wanted
an invasion of northern Norway or
northern Sumatra as he did on two
occasions in the second well he was not
going to impose his will against the
collected will of the of the Chiefs of
Staff which makes a
the the Western Way the Democratic way
of fighting wars so much more superior
because you also get of course that as a
disagreement between Franklin
Roosevelt's and Georgia C Marshall about
about ground strategy as well and so
much superior and those had to be fought
out and argued in in in gentlemanly but
tough arguments so much superior to what
was going on eighteen hundred miles
behind the Russian German front in in
the Vosges answer where the Fuhrer would
listen to his to his generals people who
had far better experience of warfare and
of Staff College than than ever he had
men like Erich Manstein and Goethe
instead and Heinz Guderian and so on
Erwin Rommel of course and and he'd
listened to them for up to an hour and
then and then go back to doing precisely
what he'd originally intended to do at
the beginning of the meeting so and you
see very much also with Stalin the way
in which Stalin at the beginning acted
as you'd expect a totalitarian dictator
to act and actually after Operation
Barbarossa and the great in German
invasion of Russia he fairly quickly
adopted the much more collegiate
approach where he would listen to
marshals like Kanye of all Zhukov or
Rokossovsky and would allow his mind to
be to be changed by them so he
yes his father as I mentioned was a was
a very serious and significant
politician but he was a he was a
sustaining 'full he was a brilliant
politician in many ways and a great
speaker but he was a distinct disdainful
man who wrote letters that no father
should ever write to any son full of
contempt and instead of allowing this to
to affect him in fact Winston Churchill
he did the opposite and when his father
died at the age of 45 in 1895 when
Churchill was 20 he sought out his
father's friends to talk to them about
his father he wrote a thousand page 2
volume biography of his father he
adopted his father's political stance
the Tory democracy stance of Benjamin
Disraeli he adopted his father speaking
stance he quoted him endlessly in
speeches he called his own son Randolph
and then in 1947 he had a very weird
moment where he believed that he had met
his father's ghost and actually this
that you can read the entire story in a
book called the dream which was edited
brilliantly again by Richard langworth
and I do recommend it because it's a
very interesting sort of psychodrama
between between the son and the father
because at no point during this long
conversation they had did he tell his
father that he had been instrumental in
helping win the second world war and so
you have this at the same time as his
mother who as I mentioned earlier saw
very little of him and and indeed really
didn't show him terribly much interest
until he became a signatory on her trust
fund at which point he did she did so to
the interest in him
but also he didn't allow that to affect
his his love for his mother and in my
early life which Larry is so right
saying is the first it's the first port
of call for anybody interested in in
Churchill and you should really read it
just before you read mine he he said of
his mother Jennie Jerome she shone for
me like the evening star brilliance but
at a distance and so you can very much
see the the drives in the man from the
from the parents so another question
Johnnie Sullivan there and I'm going to
finish by the way with a with a couple
of Churchill gags if that's all right
when belong I promise
the angel of light that century I think
well obviously
Hitler but but also Churchill very much
so Lenin and Trotsky as being as being
driving agents of darkness
Trotsky in particular he had a animus
for and and one one of the things that's
problem slightly problematical about
Churchill is that he did personally get
on with Stalin in one sort of hopes that
he wouldn't but but in a sense he had to
because when one looks just at the shift
statistics of the Second World War and
realized that for every German
five Germans killed in combat by which I
mean soldiers killed on a battlefield as
opposed to Germans being killed by the
combined bomber offensive from the air
killed in combat for every five of them
four died on the Eastern Front and so we
were killing we the Americans British
Canadians and so on were killing the
fifth German at all intents and purposes
so of course the British Prime Minister
needed to get on with Stalin but as soon
as he could break free at his great
speech in in Fulton Missouri on the 5th
March 1946 the iron curtain speech he
did denounce denounced Stalin so so I
think yes the those are the those are
the sort of troika of monsters now I
know you won't need to all get to bed
however I'm going to tell you two
Churchill anecdotes just simply because
they amuse me at the moment he in this
book there are about two hundred of
Churchill's Jags and that so my favorite
ones changed constantly that there are
two that I particularly love one which
in his killjoy way Richard will tell me
Churchill probably didn't say
nonetheless it's it's kids just sound so
much like even though you really hope
that he did and that is the time that he
met yo Kim von Ribbentrop the Nazi
foreign minister but at that time German
ambassador to London who threatened him
and at a reception and said that in the
next war Italy will be on the side of
the Third Reich and Churchill replied
well it seems any fair we had to have
them last time don't shake your head I
think I'm going down in my in his
estimation there even having told that
Jake it's just too good not to but
finally one that we know he did say
which was when his private secretary
John Koval who I mentioned earlier told
him that there Cooke had been made
pregnant as the result of a nocturnal
assignation with a man in the street in
Verona and Churchill replied obviously
not one of the two gentlemen thank you
very much indeed
you